we are absolutely at a Breaking Point
Beyond a Breaking Point and the the the
finger pointing is over I mean uh it's
always somebody else's fault the first
step to getting out of a hole is stop
digging the Border crisis exploding
migrants flooding into the us at a
staggering rate draining resources and
morale instead of spending the holidays
at home with their families border
patrol agents will face scenes like this
processing those entering the country
illegally with no slowdown in sight good
morning and welcome to America's
Newsroom I'm Brett Bear Bill and Dana
have some much needed time off morning
Jillian good to be with you Brad I'm
Jillian Turner in Washington well US
border patrol now is vastly outnumbered
with about 200 would be illegal migrants
to each single agent on the ground there
Southern border Governors say it is not
at all clear President Biden has
actually seen what is happening on his
watch take a listen has President Biden
seen photos and videos from the past
week of the Sea of people crossing into
this country illegally I understand he's
probably been briefed on it but it's
he's seen photos and videos of it
actually happening I can't attest to
what the um the content is of the
material he gets every day uh but he has
been kept apprised and briefed of course
by uh by the domestic and national
security teams on this but what's in
that content I mean I'm not part of
those discussions we got Fox team
coverage on this story for you former
acting ice director Tom homman is
standing by first though we go to Bill
maluan he's at the Border in lukeville
Arizona this morning hey
Bill Hey Jillian good uh good morning to
you some brand new numbers CBP source is
telling me that we have had about 45,000
migrant encounters at our Southern
border just since Monday that means we
could essentially fill up Yankee Stadium
in Just 4 days and we'll give you a live
look at the situation here in lukeville
it is pouring rain out here it's been
pouring rain all night but that has not
stopped the mass illegal Crossings this
is the lukeville Port of Entry which has
been closed down for weeks now because
of what's happening out here you can see
hundreds of illegal immigrants being
processed by border patrol here
underneath the Port of Entry after they
crossed illegally many of them being
handed out those Myer blankets because
it's cold and it is very rainy out here
and we'll show you how non-stop it has
been take a look at this video our team
shot yesterday here in lukeville some of
the most stunning footage we've shot out
here a single massive group of well over
700 people who crossed illegally through
a breach in the border wall yesterday
and as usual they are coming in from all
over the world we had a lot of adult men
from Africa as you mentioned Jillian the
uh agent ratio out here has gotten so
bad upwards of One agent per 200
migrants we had a chance to talk to some
guys from Ecuador who crossed illegally
that they said they're here to work and
they are going to Sanctuary cities take
a listen that on this one
tador
psylvia New York Chicago Chicago
[Applause]
Chicago and as you take a look at this
video from Eagle Pass the numbers have
been unprecedented this week remember on
Monday we had the highest single day
ever recorded of Migrant encounters with
more than 12,600 it has been absolutely
non-stop agents are completely
overwhelmed and the border patrol union
says more agents than ever are going to
have to be working on this holiday this
Christmas holiday leaving their families
because of these Mass illegal Crossings
the border patrol Union telling Fox News
uh in part quote while our agents are
more than willing to sacrifice the
holidays to protect fellow Americans
that is not what they will be doing they
will be processing the illegal border
crossers for release into the us while
large parts of the Border will be left
wide open to exploitation by organized
crime these will not be happy holidays
for the hardworking men and women of the
Border Patrol and back out here live
I'll step out again that is exactly what
they're doing right now these agents are
processing these migrants there's only a
few of them here for about 200 illegal
immigrants and we have seen the
frustration out here in recent days guys
we'll see these huge mass groups cross
border patrol will spend hours
processing uh they'll finally get the
group done they'll take a little breath
and then they look up and there's a
group of like 600 or seven showing uh
600 or 700 showing up and you just see
their heads kind of go down and the
frustration build they signed up to
patrol the border right now they feel
they are social workers essentially just
processing processing processing for
release we'll send it back to you all
right Bill stay close we'll come back to
you uh throughout the show this morning
thank you Brett for more on the board
crisis former acting ice director Tom
Holan Tom good morning thanks for being
here you know these numbers that bill
has talking about are just staggering I
know you've heard them you've dealt with
them but in December if you look at the
fiscal year 2021 2022 2023 look at these
numbers
235,000 in fiscal year 23 compared to
those past three years that is
staggering and uh how do you put you
know that to
words well there two things first Brett
um we're on a Glide path right now for
December December may be the highest
month ever recorded we're on a Glide
path to that number right now and we're
three years into Administration there's
two things that really concern me number
one is that there are certain sectors on
the southern border now where there
isn't a single board Patrol agent on
patrol they're all processing several
sectors brought every agent into the
into processing facility to process
which means their National Security
Mission has been put aside that's going
to be more fog getting across the border
more bad people more sex trafficking
women and children those that don't want
to be called the second thing is I
talked to several agents last week in in
Texas they are so busy processing and
they've been in such a push to process
quickly and release quickly they're not
doing investigative interviews they're
not going through pocket trash to find
out who they're paying how they got here
they're not doing deep D Deep D into who
these people are cuz many of these
people will lose their passports throw
their passports away before they get to
the border so The Border's got to take
their word for who they are and where
they came from and this is C caused a
whole new National Security crisis so
because of a surge the job isn't being
done and this country is at Great risk
because we don't know who these people
are we don't have time to Deep dive into
investigation well to your point the
other graphic I wanted to put up is the
terror watch list numbers and just over
the past 3 years there's more than 200
uh that we've seen on the terror watch
list and part of that is uh this
screening that you're talking
about yeah because you know each board
TR is trained very well how to how to
recognize when someone's lying to them
and and to look at like I said back when
I was an agent look at the pocket trash
look at the information in their pockets
and try to make sense of it and and
terrorist screening database is only as
good as the data we have for instance
there are a lot of terrorists in this
world that have no record unless they've
been uh captured in a criminal
investigation or a title 3 wiretap or
unless they were encountered on the
battlefield by a soldier there's no
record of them so you know that's why we
need an investigative interview which is
not being done so there are thousands of
people entering this country that and
come from can come from countries that
sponsor Terror 171 countries and some of
these countries sponsor Terror and as
you said 227 just on the southern border
last fiscal year at the same time 432 on
the northern border again I've said a
thousand times this is the biggest
National Security failure I've seen
since
9/11 you know we're talking about almost
12,000 a day now uh and just in the past
couple weeks uh Jay Johnson former
Homeland Security secretary said if he
saw 1,000 coming across a day it was a
bad day how much Tom quickly would the
remain in Mexico policy that this
Administration kind of put aside if it
was still in place would deal with this
effectively at least at some
point well first of all you're exactly
right Jay Johnson respect the man
greatly a thousand a day we all got
called into this office want to know
what we're doing about it but you know I
think what's happening here on the
remain of Mexico program is a game
changer in the Trump Administration and
look the the highest courts in Atlanta
said it's legal if they would put the
remaining Mex remain Mexico program back
in tomorrow this will be a game changer
of this Administration people going
still claim Asylum they're just going
wait wait in Mexico for the hearing it
worked for the Trump Administration
people stopped coming people stopped
selling everything they had to pay the
cartels only to come to the country and
be removed so it as a game changer and
and I've saided for a year and a half
put it back in place secure the board
and do your job it makes sense and we've
proven it's
effective Tom hman former acting ice
director Tom we really appreciate it
Merry Christmas thanks for coming on I'm
Steve Ducey I'm Brian kill me and I'm
Angley aart and click here to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page to catch
our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis